i'm pete the founder of data council in
the data community fund
and i'm really excited to have a super
inspirational
guest today gabriella de kiros from ibm
has been heavily involved in the data
science community for quite some time
and she has a really amazing story that
she's going to
tell us today about her journey to the
us from brazil
and what's inspired her to start
some amazing communities currently
gabrielle is a senior data engineering
and science manager at ibm and she leads
the team
working on ibm's contributions to a
bunch of popular open source projects
that you know
those are projects like pytorch spark
pandas
arrow tensorflow and others
and also gabrielle is the founder of our
ladies
which is an international global
community
it's a nonprofit with over 75 000
members across
193 chapters in 53 countries
um it's amazing how our ladies has grown
over the years
and most recently um gabrielle's new
nonprofit project
is ai inclusive which is bringing
diversity
to the ai community which we'll also
share with us about
in a bit so gabriella welcome thanks for
joining us
thank you pete it's a pleasure to be
here today i'm excited for this
conversation and i hope you all enjoy
yeah awesome it's really great to have
you here and
um you surprised me in our in our
pre-talk just before we
we jumped and jumped on and went live
that um
you had some beautiful slides prepared
that share different different parts of
your story so
um my first questions to you were going
to be about
your background your early career in
brazil
how you ended up coming to the u.s so
i'm going to let you take it away and
and and share a few thoughts with the
visuals that you have
awesome yeah thank you very much so
first of all a lot of things that i'm
going to talk today
uh it's available in the on the bitly
url
so bitly slash dc there is ibm
uh the slides are going to be available
uh
the links for the projects for the open
source projects are going to be
available
there's a lot of cool stuff over there
and if you if you want to
follow me on social media twitter uh
instagram linkedin
there is a bunch of links on the link
tree slash ggq
and yeah so i'm from brazil originally
um and and besides being the the founder
of our ladies and ai inclusive which i'm
going to touch on a little bit more
later pizza that we are going to talk
about this
uh i'm also a member of the r foundation
and the our foundation is the foundation
that it's behind the r um project the
language the r language the programming
language
uh that it's for data scientists data
analysts anyone working with
data and i also have a bachelor in
statistics and then two masters one epic
epidemiology and one in each statistics
so if you don't know where brazil is
brazil is based it's in south america
uh there is more than 200 million people
in the country
and the official language is portuguese
it's not spanish it's portuguese
and i come from a city called rio de
janeiro which
has around 6 million
people in that city during my back back
in the days
several years ago i did both my
undergraduates
in my in the first grad school back in
brazil one interesting thing to
mention here is that both of them they
were
free they were public and free so i
didn't have to pay
tuition uh to get my my degrees
um so back in the in the during my
bachelor
i that's when i started working with
data and that was my first exposure to r
that was back in early 2007 i guess
and i i i really like this picture and i
still have the cd
uh from the art version that i used to
to run on my computer because back in
the day the days the internet was not as
fast as we have nowadays uh we couldn't
download
especially back in brazil we couldn't
download things from the internet so
the only way to install software or what
you um
to to record in a cd and then install in
your computer so
this version was from october 2005
and now r is in the version 4. something
and when i was working as an intern
in this lab it was an epidemiology lab
where
we were using statistical models
to analyze data from air pollution data
and data from hospitals so one of the
the the studies that we worked on was
just
multi-city study on air pollution and
mortality in latin america
so it was funded by a
based in the u.s but we worked in with
three or four
countries in latin america another cool
project that i worked on
when i was working there was an
interface called
fpr and the idea was
you know r it was not very friendly back
in the days
it was very hard to learn how to program
how to use r
and and there was two barriers so we
as a epidemiologist for example we had
to
learn english as a you know a language
and then learn the programming language
art so we had to learn two things
so we thought why don't we create an
interface
that is going to sit on top of r and
it's going to be in portuguese our
native language so then we are
decreasing the entry barrier for people
to analyze data
so and the other thing is this interface
was all point and click
so if you didn't want to you didn't need
to program it just like point and click
depending on the
the type of uh of things that you want
to do
so those were two big projects that i
worked on
back in brazil and then pete let's go
back because then is when i moved to the
u.s that
was in 2012. yeah it's been 80 years
since i moved from brazil to san
francisco
2012. so i'm curious did the
um did the the gui that you created did
that support other languages
other than portuguese or was it only
portuguese it was only portuguese and
that was a
project funded by the health the
brazilian health organization
and unfortunately after several years
the we didn't have more
funding so we had to stop the project so
the project was live
for about three or four years and then
we had to
move on because we didn't have money got
it got it and is was the
project open source i missed that part
yes it was open source
open source and also like also the idea
was you know that the softwares
were so expensive the software is being
used by even the health
organization you know they had to pay
thousands and thousands of dollars to
have
software so once we introduced that one
that was based in r it was free
everything was great so that showed you
the power
of um open source uh pretty early in
your career
yeah that's right well that's exciting
um
so then then you moved to san francisco
in 2012
and i'm curious what was the community
like
in san francisco in 2012 for r
yeah so i i
it was funny so when i moved to san
francisco
i i did the parallel or the analogy that
it was kind of like going to the
disneyland
uh where you know we had so many
resources so many things going on
like very vibrant city especially if you
like
technology so i was in the in in the
place like
in the tech world um
so when i moved here i found out
something called
meetup.com the website and then i
learned that you can join several groups
and all the events were free so
a lot of those technologies i had no
idea
but i i was reading all the job
description i'm like oh
they for data science for a data
scientist
they they you need to know hadoop you
need to do data visualization you need
to know cycle
you need to know i don't know spark
spark was
later but like so many things that he
needed to know and i had no idea so i
was joining all these meetups
every night i would go to a meet-up and
then i i
for me was the best of the worlds
because as a student from
latin america our budget was very
restricted
so going to meetups was you know
combining
learning for free and having the dinner
for free
so i would go every night to the meetups
and then learn
and then eat right yeah so that was
i was just amazed like the community
like how many things we were able to
learn
uh how many resources were available
yep well i've heard it said before that
the best place to learn are is from a
cd-rom
but the next best place to learn are is
in san francisco
you must have met such interesting
people and
that must have benefited your career and
not just your learning about technology
but um being connected to that community
i can tell it was a
big breath of fresh air for you um how
else did it benefit you and inspire you
yeah it totally so you know after going
to these meetups
um i got to a place where i'm like okay
cool i learned a lot for free
and this is kind of like a cycle right
you receive and then you give back and
then you receive and then you give back
if you don't give up give back you only
receive this cycle we went
so i was thinking about this and i'm
like okay i
think i'm good and i think i'm ready to
give back
because i was not very comfortable like
i was new i didn't have anyone
here i didn't know anyone but i i had
this desire of like
giving back and then i thought
what do i know that i can share with
others right
and and then i was using r as i showed
you
i was very passionate about r and i'm
like why don't i create a group
that it's focusing our but i
didn't want to create a general r group
because one thing that i realized
when i was going to the meetups was that
the audience and even the speakers were
not diverse and then i would
i would not feel comfortable in that
environment usually
i would go i would watch the talks the
workshops
in the corner not interacting much
with the the people there
so then i'm like why don't i create a
group where i can feel
comfortable i can see people like me for
example and another
folks like me and with diverse
background like a place where
i could feel welcome with
no judgment and and safe and that's how
our ladies the organization
came together was to create a space for
us to learn together
to share knowledge and to grow together
and so you started our ladies in san
francisco first what year was that
it was october 2012. okay
well you didn't lose any time um and and
what
what were the first groups like i'm
curious
so the first event uh that
there is an interesting story the first
event was in october
and i was very excited for this first
event i'm like oh my god this is going
to be so
fun and and then
when i got there getting everything
ready and
about to start only eight people showed
up so i was a little disappointed
because i was so excited i'm like oh my
god this is going to be
awesome because you know i'm so excited
that the the venue is amazing the
content that i pre
prepared it's amazing but then only
eight people showed up
and then in the end of the the talk uh
someone came to me and said gabriella do
you know
why only eight people showed up and i'm
like why
oh it's halloween night everybody's in
the streets partying and you know san
francisco
like there's a big party in uh on
halloween night here in san francisco
that's why so
actually you are lucky to have eight
people uh
so that was the first the first ever
events that we
we put together wow that is that is
funny well i'm glad that you had a
turnout at all
and of course i know as a community
organizer
um how challenging it is sometimes
you feel a little bit on pins and
needles if you're going to have a
big group or not and um but
i guess we learned how to how to push
through all the barriers
and um you know it's our our love and
our concern and care for the community
really that
that drives us forward so um so then
then after that um our ladies was off to
the races
um how long did it take for you to start
to see the
the group expand around the world and
what was the
organization structure of the group how
did that happen
yeah so uh the the group
you know like when i created i didn't
think about like
becoming global i didn't have this
vision or
or i i or you know i wanted to create a
local community
and then in 2016 um other
folks got together with me from other
chapters and then we created a global
organization and and also we got a
funding from the art consortium
which is a project by the linux
foundation so we got some money and that
gave us the
the the what we needed in terms of like
expansion
and then that's when the our ladies
organization started to grow and then
now it's
we are in more than 50 countries and 190
cities
all over the world wow that's great
um and so all the individual chapters
are independently
organized well
not not independent in a way that they
we have a onboarding system so once
someone wants to create a chapter they
send us an email
and then we guide them through all the
the onboarding steps that they need so
then they become uh part of the official
or ladies organization
so there is a process that we go through
and and there is a lot of thinking
behind
on this and these onboarding process
got it um and what do you think the some
of the challenges are
for some of the local organizers because
you have a
the model is that you have a local
organizer who's a volunteer
um for each chapter in each city is that
right
yeah exactly yeah and and believe it or
not
the the most challenging piece is to
find a place to host the meetups
even in san francisco it's so hard to
find place to show holsters
and and also like the other the other
pieces
uh the nation like we all
we are all volunteers running the
organization we don't get
paid and we don't have enough money so
donation is something that we
lack of got it
um well that must be really exciting to
work with technical people
from all over the world um like what
have you learned about the way
the way geeks think the way data geeks
think
um differently around the world like
what what's the most surprising or
interesting to you and
in working with such a broad community
yeah i think the
the the the different cultures
uh and since we are focused on
gender minorities some countries it's
not as
well uh accept accepted
that we can have you know groups focus
on
gender minorities for example um one
one one interesting um picture that i
saw
few years ago was this meet up i don't
remember the country anymore maybe
indonesia
where you had all the women with
computers or watching the lecture
and the partners in the back taking care
of the children
so they so the woman could go and watch
the lecture
and that was just amazing to see you
know the support of
their partners so they could learn and
enter into this field
wow that's really neat yeah that's cool
um
well that's uh that's such a great story
gabriella and
i think um what happened is our ladies
has just grown so much that
um you decided to to maybe um step away
and
and are you still in an operational role
or have you moved on to other things now
yeah so no i i stepped away uh
so i could focus on other things that
were running in
the back of my mind and our ladies had a
good team behind
and i i i felt that i needed to do
something else
and that's what happened last year last
year
um i was working with
ai and then reading a lot about ai
and then we saw in the news
a lot of like facial recognition issues
algorithm bias discrimination racism
racism uh and then then a lot of things
around the affects
and then seeing all the news running
around especially in the ux and all the
discussion happening
here in the u.s in some places like
china
i was like in the the people that are
going to be affected the most for
by those algorithms are going to be the
minority groups and especially
places or countries like latin america
africa and other underserved communities
where they are not aware of those
things they don't they have no idea and
they are going to be the ones
you know being the most affected ones
and that's when
i decided to do something and i'm like
what what can i do
what what is something that i can do to
change that
and then with my experience with our
ladies i'm like
why i can why why can't i
create a a similar organization similar
structure but it's going to be focused
more on ai
instead of like being focused in a
language for example
so that's when i started ai inclusive
that was last year
and i can show you a little bit about
some of the information if
the audience is interested
in knowing in knowing a little bit more
so
our mission as a organization is to
increase the representation and
participation
of minority groups in ai so we are
creating this community to make ai
more inclusive to everybody so
we are also based in chapters and now we
have three chapters
so one chapter here in san francisco and
two chapters in brazil
one in rio de janeiro and one in
salvador
and the the we we have a mix of
things that we do so we have talks where
we bring
awareness of the issues of all the
algorithm bias and discrimination so we
we make those things aware so people
people is aware because they have no
idea
and then the second piece is around
education
in power how can we
educate them how can we provide
resources so they can enter
into the ai field so we have tutorials
we have workshops
we have tickets free tickets for
conferences
um we have a lot of like again resources
materials and then now
our next step is to partner
with both camps like data science booth
camps or courses
so we can provide scholarships to our
organization
i see that's great and so are the boot
camps themselves are they
do they sponsor the scholarship in this
case yeah they do sponsors
like it's it's they we are not creating
pretty much anything from scratch so we
are partnering
with schools and they are providing some
scholarship a percentage of scholarships
to our group
got it um i know the the boot camp world
has exploded in the us
and even europe um are the boot camps
popular as well in south america
these days they are they are and and the
barrier
which we are where we are very cautious
about or mindful about is we
don't want to just to partner with
english
spoken data data boot camps right
we want to um we want to partner with
with boot camps that are native that
native language so we are also like in
in south america so we are partnering
with boot camps that they teaching in
spanish they
teach in portuguese or in french right
so then we can make this more accessible
because not everybody knows english
and if they don't know it's going to be
hard for them to
to learn uh data science
and even if they know a little bit of
english it's going to be a lot of work
because they have to copy the content
go to translator like google translator
and then translate the content so they
have to do twice as much
work right yeah i get it
um well you've been so prolific in
in starting um two communities now
i'm i'm wondering how do you articulate
sort of the importance behind the values
um around the community i know that
in order to really build successful
non-profits or even sometimes
for-profits depending on on the nature
of the community um
it's important to be really clear about
the values and i'm wondering
um what you've learned about that and
what advice you would have for other
people who want to start communities of
their own
yeah so in our case we
don't you don't have to pay for anything
right because once you have even if it's
a small amount
but if you charge something you are
going to exclude parts of the population
that they cannot afford
so all the events are ladies they are
inclusive they are all
free of charge we do not charge any
event
we are not making any profit at all as i
said
we are all volunteers behind the
organization
um one thing that i'm also like i know
that's a lot of work
and i hope that in the future we can
have
like donations support so then we can
pay some of the folks
working uh in the organization but we
are not going to be
charging anyone in the community so
that's that's like my call
for companies and and people in general
to
try to support those groups because the
amount of work that we do
and the importance of those groups is i
mean
it's like it's huge so it's my
my my ask is please if you have
something try to donate to any any group
that is supporting communities
and as you mentioned space is even uh
at a premium in many cities many big
cities
and so um i know from being a community
organizer that
like you mentioned just finding a space
to hold an event is often the biggest
one of the biggest hurdles
um have you ever done a conference with
our ladies
like a like a multi-day conference or
have they all been um sort of individual
meetup formats
mostly individual yeah mm-hmm got it
but but one day possibly one day we are
going to have all the chapters we had
this plan
uh in the works um
where we would get all the chapters
together and
before cove before covid before the
pandemic we would get all the chapters
together
and but we again you need to have
funding
so it's very hard to organize things
like this
yeah understood well i know that from
personal experience
um well uh catheriella let's let's talk
a little bit
uh shift gears and talk a little bit
about your work at ibm because
um i know that this um community
these community values that you have
personally um
i think it's um likely shaped your
career you would probably
say and ibm is not always a company that
we think of
celebrating open source but i know that
that's changing internally and
ibm has been such a great supporter of
us at data council over the years and
um uh you know we're happy to to sort of
expose
um some of the cool open source projects
that
i know that you're contributing to and
you have teams of engineers who are
making contributions to um so i'm i want
to hear a little bit about
some of the cool projects that you're
working on at ibm and um hear a little
bit more about that
yeah that's that's very a good very good
point and i'm so glad to be working for
ibm it was the first company
that valued the work that i was doing in
open source and
with the community and i have a lot of
flexibility and freedom inside the
company to work on different projects
even though
my organization is more focused on data
and ai technologies
and you know it's not it's not it's not
recent that ibm has been contributing
a lot to open source over 25 years like
from
linux java and
and if you go to ibm website there is a
there is an open source piece and then
you can read the story
of open source contributions by ibmers
uh so we've been doing a lot of
contribution throughout the year one
thing that i
think we missed as a company
is to talk about it so we don't talk
much about it i think we
nowadays we are talking more about the
work that we do
and and the organization that i work for
which i do have some slides about it so
we can all go
together um the organization
yeah the organization that i that i work
for is called
code we we have about
30 plus open source developers and
we are building tools to make ai
accessible and
available to everybody so
let me go to the next slide so
we have like several open source
projects that we create so it's
we create inside ibm and then we make
available that open source
to the community and there are some
other open source projects
that were not created by us but we do
contribute
to so let me show like a data science
pipeline so
as a data scientist as a developer uh
there are several steps that we go
through
so we get the data we analyze the data
we do some kind of like modeling
we deploy the model and then there is
some kind of like maintenance
so projects that we contribute to
are apache spark apache aero uh
tensorflow pi torch onyx
um then we have kubeflow we have
pandas we have scikit-learn that we
contribute
jupiter we have several committers in
the organization that are
committed in the jupiter
project we have commuters on spa
apache spark apache arrow commuters and
pie torch
and so on so we do contribute
a lot and we also create a lot of
projects such as
data asset exchange that i'm going to
touch on a little bit
uh interior there is a now a light a
very cool project that was just launched
i think it was beginning of this year uh
then we have the model website exchange
and then the whole umbrella on the
trustworthy
ai projects that came from
the research ibm research but we
collaborated
with them right so we we contribute and
we also
advocate for the open source
technologies
and can i go in and talk a little bit
about the project yeah
yeah please please tell us yeah so uh
my team we are around 10 open source
developers
uh working in open source projects and
we have two main projects that we
work on uh one is the model asset
exchange
and the other one is the data asset
exchange
one is more focused on model on deep
learning models the other one is more
focused on data notebooks
and the the mod os exchange is a place
for developers data scientists
to find and use free and open source
deep learning models so there is a
variety of domains
so if you have you are looking for
models to
analyze um image there are several
models on that
and then you have for text you have for
video and so on
there are a lot of like different
frameworks being used so we have models
running on tensorflow pytorch
onyx um and and in this
slide to have some uh examples but when
what i want to show here is when you go
to the model asset exchange page
we have more than 30 open source deep
learning models
and they can be deployable or trainable
you know all the coding is available on
our github repo you can use
the api through python or even through r
you can also try using the swagger
you can also use a web app that we
created on top of the model which is
pretty cool
and we also are
very careful when creating a project
because we think
not only about the project as you know
the coding piece
but there is there is a thinking or
you know we care about the education as
well like
can we provide tutorials for the users
on how to use these projects can we
create interesting examples so they can
also
take a look and try to expand for the
use cases
so one of the examples that i want to
show real quick
is on on some models we try to
create web apps or examples on how to
consume
these models and there is one where you
know there is a web app that recognizes
yoga poses so if you are doing some yoga
poses it kind of like recognizes
there is one of my favorite ones which
you
use your arms to make music and
and and this one was created
um using a human post estimator model
and tensorflow
and it kind of like mimics a parameter
is a instrument by uh that was created
in the 20s
and where you use your arms to make
these very interesting sounds
and let me show you a real quick example
here that i did
in another conference where i was
recording myself using this web app and
then trying to do some
music even though it was not very
successful because i i
i was just playing around
[Music]
so
that's cool that's a one-person symphony
yeah uh and then and then the other
uh the other project is the data asset
exchange uh
where we have data that comes from
ibm research or 33 parties
30 parties and they are published both
projects they are published under
friendly license which means that you
can use the enterprise
and we have the care on like having
everything in a standardized
way and this this project also comes
with a lot of notebooks a lot of
materials in these projects as well
um and just to close repeat this because
i know that we are running
uh you know we have a little bit more
time but now you're good
other than the the more like traditional
open source data science open source
projects
as i mentioned before we are very
engaged in the trusted ai life cycle
using open source
so we have four open source projects
that one is around robustness the other
one is around
fairness the the third one is around
explainability and the fourth one is
around
lineage and they are all open source
um all of them are available in python
but the aif 360 is available in yar
as well and they have
demos that you can play with and then
notebooks and you can
use again in your enterprise application
there is ibm products
that runs with these packages as well
and this year three of the first three
projects they were
they were donated to the linux
foundation so now these three projects
are
under the linux foundation
yeah there are other projects that i
work on that we
as a team work on but these are the main
ones
that's very cool well um ai
accountability responsibility fairness
these are such important topics right
now
so um it's great to see the efforts
at ibm not just to contribute and create
these projects but also to open source
them
yeah exactly yeah and we are doing more
and more work in this area it's
it's a very interesting area it's an
area that is increasing and we have
a lot of for work on this
yeah excellent um do you have any any
more slides that you want to share with
us gabrielle or is that the last one
yeah i do have some kind of like call to
action
which is like other than you know
following the ai inclusive
um on twitter instagram
is to
she that all the material that i was
sharing here the slides the links
everything that i was talking about it's
available on our github repo
all the presentations that we are doing
we are trying to put in this place and
if you feel like you want to be up to
date or
or follow where we are doing this repo
we can always
start our repo and and that's it that's
all i have
in terms of slides but if we have
questions or anything
else that you want to touch on i would
be happy to talk about
that's great that's great gabriella um
well thank you for
for sharing your experience with us um i
think it's really
inspirational um you know how you were
able to to end up in san francisco and
and to appreciate and embrace the
community and then also to to really
give back and start to build
communities of your own um so yeah thank
you
thank you for sharing all of your time
with our ladies and with a inclusive and
with us
and it's been really great to have you
here
yeah thank you very much and i hope to
see you around and
and again remember to support the
communities the organization the
projects that are open source
it's so important to have this type of
communities around
absolutely yeah i i completely agree and
um we've published a bunch of links in
the chat
alongside this conversation so people
will be able to
jump in become a member potentially
a donate space for meetups when we start
to meet in person again
which i'm hopeful will not be too long
we'll see
but i know that that uh that's such an
important part of running a
irl community and so i'm hoping that
folks will raise their hand and
and be willing to support in multiple
ways
so um just a couple notes before we end
the show um
remember to subscribe to
uh the the youtube channel for data
council and that's a good way to get
notifications of our upcoming dc
thursdays events we have
a bunch of awesome events planned um
through december and then into january
so we look forward to seeing you at some
of our next events
and also don't forget to leave us
feedback via the response form
that's posted next to the video it helps
us know
what's resonating what we can improve
and how to better serve the community
so both gabrielle and i would appreciate
your feedback in that regard
and finally dc thursday is becoming a
bit of a thing we've done a bunch of
episodes
um over the last six months and you can
uh on demand play any of them in our
playlist on youtube so make sure you
check out some of the previous guests as
well and
and feel free to share the episodes with
your friends um
so that's it for now um thanks again to
gabriella and
we'll see you all next time